Now that we’ve heard that our clown
prince of piracy is an Emperor of the Sea,
we need to talk about Buggy, chop-chop. How
did this flashy character ascend to the top of
the pirate pecking order? How did this fool
fool everyone and gain such immense power?
Definitely not intentionally… probably.
Or could it be that Buggy is masking his true
power level? Buggy did after all tank a direct
hit from Mihawk’s black blade. There aren’t too
many characters that can do that and live to tell
the tale. Sure, his fruit is immune to cutting,
but is that still the case when we’re talking
about a haki-infused strike? He also took out an
awakened zoan user in Impel Down and threatened to
challenge Whitebeard himself. Not only was
he a regular member of the Roger pirates,
but was also invited by SHanks to join
his new crew, after Roger’s death.
So, since we don’t know yet, what direction Oda
will take this in, let’s just assume for a second,
that Buggy is indeed an extremely powerful pirate,
similar to Shanks, who has simply been hiding his
true strength. So when Luffy faces Buggy in orange
town, he would obviously be way out of Buggies
league and the only way he could win this fight
would be by Buggy underestimating him and being
outsmarted. Weirdly enough, you could argue that
Buggy never was interested in killing Luffy. He
only wanted his treasure back and go for Luffy’s
slash Shanks slash Roger’s straw hatm, that still
carries the scars of his attack. The reason
Buggy lost, was because he got outmanouvered in
his rage. And given that he not only succesfully
escaped Impel down, keeping his true powers secret
there as well, but survived all types of monster
attacks druing the war at Marienford, it would
at least fit within the established story, that
Buggy is a wolf in disguise. An actual Yonko.
I’d be aboslutely on board with that, but for now,
let’s look at the facts or at least
what Oda wants us to think about Buggy:
Itt semms that our clown gained his power the same
way that many powerful people in this world do:
Through no “real” work or effort of their own!
Along with a dash of cunning and trickery, and
in this case a natural aptitude for mass media
manipulation! And, of course, having a pretty
cool devil fruit power doesn’t hurt. Though, he
could stand to use it a bit more effectively.
For many, the hierarchy of the One Piece world
is merit based. Luffy and Coby, for instance,
had to fight tooth and nail to get where they
are today. They started as weaklings and through
insane willpower and determination have made
names for themselves in the world. However,
many other characters are granted power in ways
that have little to do with their own will or
strength. Characters like the Celestial
Dragons rule the world just because they
happened to be born as Celestial Dragons and
the same is true for royalty like King Riku or
Princess Vivi, though they don’t
abuse their power in the same way.
Our two favorite recently defeated
Yonkou, Big Mom and Kaidou,
ascended to Emperor status because they
had unnatural inborn strength. Judging
by their flashbacks, they didn’t have to
train very hard to amass their physical
prowess - Big Mom was just an ungodly strong
child, taking down giants as a little kid.
Buggy, however, wasn’t born with his power - in
fact, in terms of physical strength, he still
really doesn’t have much to speak of. Instead,
the clown star Buggy had to depend on a few
other factors - like his personal connections
and the good old fashioned power of lying!
It should come as little surprise that Buggy has
come so far in the story. In a manner similar to
Blackbeard, Buggy has also paralleled Luffy’s
journey throughout his travels. His story,
like Luffy’s, harkens back to the East Blue.
After all, he was one of the first major villains
to appear in the series. He was also the first
antagonist to wield a devil fruit power, with his
chop-chop fruit proving a formidable challenge for
the early crew to overcome. It was thanks to Buggy
slashing the straw hat that Nami got to learn what
it meant to Luffy, indirectly leading to one of
the most emotional moments in the series, when
Luffy gave her the hat in Arlong Park. As Luffy’s
bounty has grown arc by arc, Buggy has scaled
with him, becoming a Shichibukai and now a Yonkou.
Everyone assumes that Blackbeard is Luffy’s
greatest rival to become the Pirate King…but
does our favorite clown have a
shot? I’m not going to lie - it
would be hilarious for Buggy to
claim the mantle temporarily.
Let’s explore how exactly Buggy fooled everyone
and became an Emperor of the Sea. The first way
Buggy came into his current power is that he
has the kind of networking connections that
any LinkedIn user would be jealous of. After all,
they say it’s all about who you know and Buggy
knows a real who’s who of the pirate world.
Though, he probably doesn’t know the
character literally named…Who’s Who.
Buggy probably would have rotted away in an Impel
Down cell for the rest of his days if it weren’t
for his connection to the real hero of the story,
Luffy. Being dragged along by the absolute force
of nature that is Monkey D. Luffy, he managed
to escape this supposedly inescapable prison.
During the Marineford War, many of the
escapees rallied to his side largely
because it was revealed that he was a
part of the former Pirate King’s crew.
Surely an associate of Gol D. Roger himself must
be a powerful leader - the kind of person you’d
want to follow if you want to hedge your
bets on the future of the pirate world.
Buggy’s ability to gain power based on his
previous associations with pirates like Luffy,
Shanks, and Roger, of course, are based in no
part on his own strength (which is lacking to
say the least). However, this doesn’t stop an
increasing number of people from joining him.
When Shanks approached the Gorosei
to talk about a “certain pirate”,
could our assumptions have been wrong
in thinking he was talking about Luffy
or Blackbeard. Perhaps the true threat to the
state of the world is none other than Buggy-Sama.
And, of course, we can’t underestimate the power
of lying. If Buggy truly does have a strength,
this is it. Buggy is cut from the same cloth as
Usopp, another habitual liar. Strangely enough,
whereas you would expect a story
to impart moral lessons such as
“lying is bad”, One Piece in general has
not taken a hard stance on dishonesty.
Whereas Buggy lies for personal gain,
we see Usopp lie for justified purposes.
Both Usopp and Buggy actually inhabit a
role in literature called the “trickster
archetype.” An archetype, by the way, is a
heavily recurring character or story element
that pops up again and again
throughout literature and mythology.
The “trickster” is a character that is cunning,
deceitful - sometimes malicious, but at other
times heroic. On the sinister side, we have
figures like Loki…so we may meet another trickster
in Elbaf. On the more delightful side, though, we
have Bugs Bunny (whose name sounds suspiciously
close to Buggy if you ask me). Perhaps an even
more apt comparison from the Looney Tunes canon,
though, is Wile E. Coyote, based on the Coyote
characters of Native American mythologies.
Like Buggy, Wile E. Coyote also frequently
has his own explosives blow up in his face.
I’m starting to suspect that Buggy Balls
must be manufactured by the ACME corporation.
Usopp uses his lies to bring joy to others like
Kaya or to ultimately work toward an ultimate
good, such as Luffy becoming the Pirate King.
However, Buggy uses his lies for immoral purposes
and mostly for his own personal gain. Is Buggy
Oda showing us what an evil Usopp would be like?
No. No, probably not. But it is Oda showing us
two different takes on the same classic archetype.
Buggy crafts lies in order to bring
tons of Impel Down escapees to his crew.
Long before the prisoners on Dressrosa
would proclaim the glory of God Usopp,
Buggy gained an almost religious following
after his followers believed he was able
to open the giant gate preventing their escape.
And what makes him such an effective liar? Well,
it helps that he wholeheartedly believes his
lies thanks to his massive delusions of grandeur.
We might also be able to speculate that Buggy is
a little smarter than he lets on. His followers
listen to every word he speaks with adoration.
They think he’s an all-powerful genius. However,
it’s pretty clear to the audience that
his ravings come from his ego more than
his intellect. But could we be wrong? Has
he engineered more of his rise to fame than
initially meets the eye? After all, it
would appear that he shares “the most
dangerous power in the world” - just like Luffy,
Buggy manages to amass allies wherever he goes.
Another reason that Buggy the Clown has ascended
to Yonkou status is because of a grasp on the
media. Other than Big News Morgans, there are
few characters in the One Piece world that have a
better handle on how to manipulate public opinion
through mass media. At the Marineford War,
Buggy notably took control of a surveillance
snail to broadcast flashy messages to the
world. This hugely increased his notoriety
and allowed him to become a Shichibukai.
His narcissistic, megalomaniacal
personality couldn’t stand for
Monkey D. Luffy drawing all the attention
for himself at the Summit War. Instead,
he brought himself front and center and
proclaimed himself as Buggy the Magnificent.
I’m actually super curious what Buggy’s new Yonko
bounty will turn out to be. More than Luffy’s 3
Billion i would bet. But no matter how much it is,
it’s way way more than my lousy little bounty of
61 million berries, 100 berries for each of my
subscribers. So while buggy seems out of reach,
this dripping man right here isn’t with 99 M on
his head. And so we have been fighitng for over
a month now to not lose the wild race to 100M
berries against Trebol. Please help to beat him
by subscribing and getting freshly pressed
One PIece content in return every single week.
Now, True to his status as a clown,
Buggy is a natural performer,
able to draw in an audience. It’s not just
his shiny red nose that garners such attention
- in fact, he’d really rather not
bring too much attention to that…
Instead of the physical strength that allowed
pirates like Big Mom and Kaidou to take the
position of Yonkou, Buggy rolled a Nat 20 on
charisma and has been making waves ever since.
Of course, this video wouldn’t be complete
without speaking about Buggy’s devil-fruit power,
so let’s talk about the chop-chop fruit. He’s not
the most effective user of his fruit in combat,
but he has used it in ways that play up the other
qualities that make him so renowned. In this way,
he’s almost an inverse of Luffy, who used what
we initially thought was a fairly weak fruit
and became a powerhouse. On the other hand,
Buggy uses a fruit that is full of potential
and then usually just ends up tied up
on the ground, unable to reform himself.
Most characters in One Piece who possess
devil fruit powers have character traits
that perfectly reflect the powers bestowed
upon them by Goda. Blackbeard is the
ultimate force of darkness in the world.
Galdino is a dummy (of the wax variety).
So how does the Chop-Chop fruit
perfectly resemble Buggy? Well,
on the outside Buggy always looks like he has
it all together…but in reality, he’s in pieces.
Take his post time-skip appearance, where
we see that he’s wearing a comically large
outfit and through the manipulation of his
fruit he appears to be gigantic in stature.
Little do most of his followers know that
under this facade, there’s no substance to
this giant figure of piracy. Or could it
be that just like that oversized costume,
he’s hiding his true power and abilities? Was
he underestimated being from the East Blue,
supposedly the “weakest sea”? Could this
brother of Shanks just be laying low until
the time to make his move and find the greatest
treasure of all - the One Piece. After all,
there are few things that Buggy
enjoys more than treasure hunting.
And so the big looming question that has opened
up now is: Will Buggy fail his upwards all the
way to becoming the King of the Pirates? Or he
actually a Yonko-level character in disguise?
I think no matter what the answer is, it seems
clear that Oda-sensei has set Buggy up to play
a much much bigger role during the end-game of One
Piece than any of us could have ever guessed. he
might end up being the same sort of schemer and
wire-puller as shanks, and spaking of Shanks,
if you want to understand why he stole
Luffy’s devil fruit from the marines,
you should really check
out that video, right here.